letting jerry help morty with homework
i don't know how many times i have to
say this but if you have the flu stay
home
does he mean stay home and don't go to
the dance or stay home and don't go to
school
because you shouldn't be at school if
you have the flu and if you're not at
school how would you hear this
announcement
why is this announcement also episode of
a cartoon from 2014 predicts how selfish
humans are when it comes to protecting
others from a rampaging virus
the flu season dance is about awareness
not celebration
you don't bring dead babies to passover
well someone's not getting invited to my
passover celebration
hey wait a minute where did jessica's
friends go
try not to worry about it morty you're a
good kid izzy though
in this episode alone he asked rick to
help him essentially roofy jessica so i
think a little more honest parenting is
in order jerry
what the [ __ ] is the purple meat on
jerry's sandwich ah
well i remember feeling that way about a
young lady named your mom
and that's not an urban diss but it
works so much better as an urban diss
in fact that's a pretty epic your mom
joke that he just ruined pink jerry
we have ice we have no ice rick is a
dick to carbonated sodas
wait a minute did rick go into the
kitchen to get
orange juice does rick seem like the
kind of guy who drinks orange juice
without adding the vodka
yeah i'm just going to check on your mom
and apparently leave out the mustard
mayo an open orange juice pitcher and an
unstarted sandwich
do you want food poisoning jerry because
this is how you get food poisoning jerry
and ants a hair morty i need one of your
hairs this isn't game of thrones
my favorite part of every episode of
game of thrones was when the csi team
came in and solved the case
there's a calculator of some sort on the
right side of this love potion making
machine here but when it cuts to the
wide shot the calculator is on the left
side of the spout your continuity errors
will be the death of you rick and morty
geez did this brad kid go to the dance
in his usual high school attire just
adding a tie that's actually pretty
funny but i'm singing it anyway
not that this is the point but shouldn't
brad already have the flu considering
jessica was
already sneezing at school today and he
ran right into her sneeze mist earlier
brad got sick immediately is that how
the flu works how come you're not at
this stupid dance everyone loves so much
screw that i don't want to get sick so
wait summer are you saying you're
backing out of our trip to south dakota
cartoon dry humping jessica get a hold
of yourself
the flu love potion combo which made
brad sick in second should already be
running
rampant through this gym considering it
was in the punch and the air
conditioning but it waits until someone
scolds jessica before taking over the
entire school
still being proud of a swimming
championship nearly a hundred years
later
whipped up an antidote it's based on
praying mantis dna they mate once and
then they you know decapitate the
partner
science i i basically mixed this with a
more contagious flu virus why did you
need to mix it with a flu virus when
everybody at school already has the flu
these serums they don't work on anybody
related to you genetically i mean
thank god but that still is a serum of
the highest convenience
the only thing that is known is how cute
he is
i love him so much i want to make love
to him
how did these news anchors even get to
their jobs if they were obsessed morty
loving praying mantis creatures
also where did they get a picture of
morty that quickly that's almost
creepier than the love potion
[Applause]
how is this virus already spread to
other countries the news station was
hard enough to buy but at least it was
potentially local
and this is going to be an issue for the
rest of the episode so instead of
bringing it up several more times i'll
just add 10 cents here
wait so everyone knows where morty lives
all of a sudden what the heck
is that a morty doll how did they
manufacture that i'm glad we saved all
those horses
why did you short the glue industry how
did the flu mantis concoction get all
the way out to the horse hospital
have people been drive by sneezing
around this place i'm mr crowbar
and this is my friend who is also
a crowbar i can't imagine a world where
jerry actually deserves a sin off but
i'm giving him one regardless if people
from other countries are whiffing the
antidote already wouldn't they have a
period of time when they turn back to
normal before morphing into these
abominations that's what happened to
everyone else
how did this guy's underwear stay on and
intact throughout all these
transformations
here's another thing rick made the love
potion for morty using his dna and
that's why his family wasn't affected
but he made the mantis potion in the
every animal on earth potion without
morty's dna so why aren't they also
turning into trauma creatures right now
hold on mad jerry fury road mad max
jerry road
furious jerry maximum mad max and
furious presents rhodes and shaw
the fury is there any reason for beth
and jerry to get out of the car and
fight these things they were doing just
fine running over all of them
what's the goal of coming out to
purposely kill these things other than
to pad this episode's run
time boy morty i really cronenberg the
world up didn't i
don't be so hard on yourself rick the
world doesn't look too much like in
butterfly
here morty put this on while i do a
little bit of scouting why does morty
need to wear this thing while rick does
his scouting what computer works just
because someone's wearing a backpack
apparatus
okay so we're about to find out that
this is one of the infinite realities
that original rick found where a
parallel universe rick was able to get
everything back to normal and the rick
and morty we see here
are not the original rick and morty team
which is what the show wants you to
think
so why is this universe's rick and morty
just now getting back to the house
after a newspaper was published
explaining how everything went back to
normal
the answer is don't think about it it's
not like we can do this every week
anyways we get three or four more of
these tops
yeah but that violates the cinemasins
and therefore tv sins charter where we
were told to think too deeply about it
it's too convenient
yes you don't follow the same rules and
you definitely shouldn't because nothing
creative would ever get made but that
doesn't mean that we're not sinning you
for this
replace the dead rick and morty in a
different universe bit i'd grown super
fond of the original summer beth and
jerry and now i'm gonna have to be cool
with exact replicas with no differences
whatsoever
you owe us an apology also you only get
three or four more of these tops
has rick ever watched anything on
network television leaving the
refrigerator door open
he's got lifeless eyes black eyes like a
doll's eyes
glad summer could hopefully write jaws
on this box in case you didn't know the
reference but what happens when she
decides to do the englishman who went up
a hill but came down a mountain
not enough room on the box to explain
that reference then
bob left the new flash did you know that
we create monthly exclusive videos for
our sitting club members bonus outtakes
i don't know peter meth is a hell of a
drug extra sins videos
strange things are afoot at the circle k
and even member chosen sin commentaries
i love this
i love this this kind of of a sin
because it's just
it's so silly pick our next video and
see the exclusives at patreon.com
cinemasins or click the link in the
description below spiderman is not a
parade you do not need to stop traffic
for spiders
hey jessica hello peter
what's happening i throw balls far i'm
gonna
oh yo you know son
you're not a kid anymore oh no i go to
health class dad i already know all this
stuff
but what people call love it's just a
chemical reaction that compels animals
to breed
biochemically no different than eating
large
quantities of chocolate there's
something special about you morty
you reached out you touched it by the
heart
rip my clothes off and mate with me for
life it's really important in this pose
that you arch your back and keep it flat
at the same time
you're you're you're just a little
creepy creep person you're just this
penny stealing wannabe criminal
man